bonjour jean françois corty merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france dans des cas de
pandémie comme celle-ci faut-il une
coordination mondiale des moyens
médicaux à disposition des pays dont on
voit bien aujourd'hui que la situation
est tendue
la plupart des vins sont aujourd'hui
concernés par l'épidémie on voit qu'il y
ait aussi à l'échelle européenne des
difficultés de coordination sur cette
crise même si des gestes de solidarité
sont en place des malades notamment de
la france qui sont affairés vers
l'allemagne il faut absolument en
coordination pour aussi écouté les
recommandations oms qui rappelle la
nécessité d'un compliment un petit soir
qu'ils soient leurs tendances it et de
protéger les panneaux de faire en sorte
que matane production soit produit et
que les patients sont réunis aujourd'hui
dans une logique de médecine de
catastrophe
beaucoup de patients on entend toujours
de prendre en charge sans traitement
efficace à toute forme elle même s'il ya
des controverses tous les coquines et
sans accent tout sous lequel les états
se coordonner en sorte que la suisse
soit appliquée justement les pays du g20
peuvent-ils s'unir pour donner les
moyens financiers nécessaires pour
trouver un vaccin ou ce que c'est pas
possible que simplement on sait aujourd
hui que le délai pour le vaccin
plusieurs mois en france aujourd'hui
c'est de produire en branle des tests
qui parle un trouble une visibilité sur
eminem et que l'épidémie de protéger les
personnes et qui en seront affectées les
soignants et puis de créer les
conditions en tours rapides sur les
études en cours notamment sur
l'efficacité d'un tel outil nous disons
4 euros ou d'un quarteron différents
types de médicaments
l'enjeu majeur c'est évidemment que les
étals se soutiennent mais que l'oci ont
créé les conditions comment des pays en
guerre notamment l'autre pays qui s'en
ressent s'y limiter la pression
s'unissent ibid s'atténue je pense en
avoir c'est un paradoxe
georges jobé les -100 kg le g20 je pense
conclut unis mènent les civils sont très
exposés manière on espère que dans ces
conflits la latence mois s'annoncent
indécis pour que l'espagne puisse t elle
a également discuté pour les
humanitaires aujourd'hui du fait des
limitations d'humidité de pouvoir
intervenir voir l'augmentation des cas
on a ce truc dans marais du sud mais
aussi en afrique du nord amérique
centrale
il faut aussi se préparer longtemps
c'est une solidarité internationale y
avoir beaucoup de drames si les pays du
g20 non seulement s'organise pas entre
médecine et génère pas une assistance
pour les pays en difficulté le mot
solidarité un ressort à face à cette
crise sanitaire mondiale on le voit en
ce moment en israël et avec la palestine
a qui a connu son premier mort dû aux
coronavirus dans la gestion d'une
pandémie l'économie mondiale montre
hotels ses limites notamment sur la
production de masques ou de médicaments
qui se fait en chine
l épicentre de l'épidémie du coup et qui
en pénurie maintenant pour les autres
les autres pays nous voit bien qu'il ya
deux ans je veux maintenir des systèmes
de sortie ne serait plus économique
effectivement elle est pas grave
continue ce qu'il y sera animée que
l'économie sera ne sera qu'un outil que
l'important aujourd'hui c'est nous
soutenir la production de médicaments en
urgence des masques du matin
et comme test qui va falloir utiliser
dans les pays du g20 ont mené à
l'échelle mondiale la solidarité oui
elle a pourtant tout revoir ces
conditions aujourd'hui avoir un système
de santé solidaire et aso avec les
services publics sort et d'autre de la
solidarité dans la politique publique
c'est ça qui permet d'être plus
conséquent plus organisés tous les soirs
entre les épidémies de ce style
l'occident est en train de s'en rendre
compte
après des dizaines d'années des actions
structurelles ultralibérale qui vient
des services publics des pays d'afrique
continent africain sont en difficulté
depuis longtemps le match noir aussi les
soutenir et gérard centre ou de service
public et l'accès aux semences soit en
en plus facile de céder un enjeu
d'urgence aujourd'hui mais c'est quelque
chose sur les téléphones très rapidement
un vraiment à quelle drôle d'association
comme médecins du monde en période de
pandémie sont ils mieux préparé plus
efficace que les états ou les
organisations internationales
toutes les organisations se soumettre
sans frontières et sanogo sont en
difficulté aujourd'hui j'ai mangé les
équipes
sungard ont été contraintes de sécurité
des placements et les consultants sont
opposés à supputer dans du matériel
difficultés de demander des équipes ne
se dit protégée aussi ses équipes
qu'elles soient locales ou
internationales ce contexte rougier pas
de vaccin les associations se préparent
à faire face au vannes oc mais aussi ces
associations se mobilisent et dans les
pays du nord notre système de santé
je pense qu on est pris par le temps
malheureusement jean françois corty
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin généraliste et ex directeur des
opérations internationales de médecins
du monde